everyone welcome to the Commission's
restroom and to this statement by
Commissioner Malmstrom on the use
proposals ideas on WTO modernization and
also to address an issue that will be
high on the agenda of next week
United Nations General Assembly the
Global Alliance for torture free trade
the Commissioner will make a statement
and then she'll be able to answer other
questions that you might have on these
and other topics without further ado
commissioner
thank you vets thank you very much
Daniel good morning ladies and gentlemen
yes today the Commission is publishing
some of our initial ideas to reform the
WTO the World Trade Organization and
global trade rules this paper is online
with a press release and after the
midday briefing there will be a
technical briefing in this very room for
those of you who have particular
interests as you know over the past
several decades the multilateral trading
system has provided predictability and
stability for companies economies across
the world it has helped economies to
growth and lift in hundreds of millions
of people out of poverty the appellate
body a very important part of the WTO
system to resolve trade conflicts has
been one of the most successful
international bodies for settling
disputes WTO members have generally be
good at complying with its ruling but
now the WTO system is slowly grinning to
a halt it is probably in the steepest
crisis ever since the start of this
century the world has witnessed rapid
economic growth technological changes
that has transformed not only trade
routes but also the very way in which we
trade and the result has been bigger
gaps in the rules of WTO either because
rules have become outdated or because of
the absence of rules in many areas for
instance just two examples market
distorting subsidies often channeled
through state-owned enterprises they go
unchecked because the current rules
don't cover them properly or e-commerce
the rules don't cover ecommerce at all
it's a new and very important area of
trade and that leaves big chunks of the
new digital economy out
site agreed and enforceable rules and
WTO is a member driven organization so
it can't simply reform itself the
responsibility lies only within its
members another important issue I
mentioned the dispute settlement
mechanism that is the core in a WTO
ability to function in a meaningful way
and the applet body is on the verge of
paralysis right now because the
nomination of new judges to replace
those who are retiring are being blocked
by the US another example many member
countries in the WTO ignore their
transparency obligations not being open
with a trade policy when it comes to
government support for instance they
have an obligation to report that but
they don't
so the WTO is now able to function
efficiently with these behaviors and
that means we are not able to secure a
level playing field for business key
members are not supporting the system
but opening for unilateral measures with
effects that we unfortunately know too
well so the WTO must adapt or it will be
in serious trouble and everybody will be
hurt but of course the most vulnerable
countries will suffer the most and only
the members can change this organization
and that is why in the EU who depend on
fair transparent rule-based trade for
our economic prosperity want to take a
leading role in pushing for reforms here
we are publishing some ideas today we
are discussing this with member states
and European Parliament of course and we
want to start discussions with other WTO
members how we can make the system more
efficient for everybody so you will see
in these papers that we talk about how
we can update the international trade
rulebook
so it's fit for purposes for the global
economy looking into new rules or
updating old ones in several areas
tackling forced technology transfers and
industrial subsidies for instance it
looks at how we can strengthen the WTO
monitoring role to make committed
committees and trade policies poor trade
policy reviews more efficient and to
sanction WTO members if they repeatedly
fail
to meet their obligation it discusses
how we can work in in new areas without
everybody agree today a couple handful
even one member can block others from
even discussing new area so we need to
see if we can work with pleura laterals
that are open and inclusive in order to
move forward in important areas such as
e-commerce and we also look at how we
can overcome the deadlock of the dispute
settlement system making specific
proposals to address the concerns that
has led to the blocking of appointment
of judges
these improvements could improve the
dispute settlement make it more
efficient and timely and unable the
enable the judges to focus substance so
as I said we are working with member
states on this European Parliament and
also with many other parties for
instance we have a three-way talk with
the US and Japan and we will be meeting
again next week and we will also start
discussions with China one of the
outcomes of the EU China summit this
summer was to set up a working group on
on WTO issues and I just came back from
Argentina g20 trade ministerial meetings
there also there was a collective joint
statement that we do need to work to
reform and modernize the WTO so we will
continue this discussion the coming and
the coming weeks and put even more
concrete proposals on the table and let
me also take this opportunity to tell
you about an important event taking
place in New York next week on Monday
here the EU is leading the way in
efforts to stop trade in goods that can
lead to torture or death penalty so in
New York on Monday there will be the
first ministerial meeting for the
alliance of torture free trade you might
remember that last September in New York
together with Argentina and Mongolia the
EU launched this initiative with a goal
to end trade in goods used for capital
punishment or torture and over the past
few decades more and more countries
worldwide had committed themselves to
eradicate
death penalty torture and inhuman and
degrading treatment but still many
countries continue to systematically
carry out torture and the death penalty
using products that are tracked traded
and shipped internationally and this is
unacceptable and that's why we have set
up the alliance behind me you can see
some examples of the types of terrible
goods that we are trying to bet that
these products exist they can be bought
and they are images and videos also
available for on our website more than
60 countries from all over the world
have joined the alliance for torture
free trade so far and we have been
focusing on four areas working towards
controlling and restricting exports
including putting exports ban in places
like we have in in the EU second to set
up a platform for customs authorities to
monitor trade flows and identify new
products third providing technical
assistance to help countries to put
legislation in place and fourth
exchanging best practices for
enforcement and just before the summer
we had a meeting here in Brussels that I
shared to say share know-how and
resources with countries who want to
introduce tough export controls and at
the ministerial meeting in New York on
Monday we'll be looking at how we can
keep up the international momentum to
stop this trade we'll be hearing from
experts and we hope that more countries
will join the Alliance at that occasion
and importantly we will discuss how to
launch work towards a binding United
Nation Convention to ban it so this is
what I wanted to say just before ending
wild I am on the other side of the
Atlantic I am also going on Wednesday to
Montreal for the first birthday
celebrations of seta the Canadian
agreement meeting with the Canadian
Trade Minister and take stock of how the
implementation of the agreement is going
the actual anniversary is this week on
Friday there will not be any birthday
cakes here in the press room but there
will be material that we can share with
you videos
examples and statistics of how the
the EU countries are benefiting from
from this agreement as from a Friday so
that's what